for decades we've been searching for
signs of life on other planets but
haven't been able to find anything and
perhaps that isn't altogether surprising
the surfaces of other worlds are harsh
environments where life seems impossible
but what if we went below the surface a
company called honeybee robotics is
developing a drill that can take our
search for extraterrestrial life below
the ice and rock of places like Mars
white drill well we want to go below the
surface and learn the history of the
planetary body and at the same time find
life the problem with Mars is that our
first couple of meters have been
oxidized and radiated which means all
the potential microorganisms died and so
if you want to find it's something you
have to go literally hundreds of meters
below the surface and that's where the
drilling comes in honeybee has been
building instruments for nasa's mars
rover since 2003 but designing a drill
that can guide itself underground an
alien world is a significantly bigger
challenge of course the potential payoff
is bigger too to test their drill
prototype the engineers at honeybee are
trying it out at a gypsum quarry in
Southern California on my mark three two
one mark
the drill itself is actually a probe
that's tethered to a long cable it's
designed to burrow kilometers through
ice and rock then be hoisted back to the
surface to make that possible the drill
has to rely on solar energy using far
less power than that black and decker
you bought at Home Depot the big Beck
are concerned is power so this has to be
solved and that do it we've been really
focusing on developing efficient
drilling mechanisms powerful but using
very little power it runs off of about
200 watts which is about the size of two
light bulbs right here I'm going to
disengage the anchors and you can winch
it up
of course to find alien microbes this
drill has to do a lot more than just put
a hole in the ground it also needs to
analyze what it finds below so the druid
soft could be sort of a reconnaissance
system you drill down you learn what's
below the surface if you find something
interesting you pull the drill out and
you dump their the sample into the
instruments and they can essentially
analyze some we have the UV LEDs which
will help us detect any micro organisms
that can emit any biofluorescence here's
another one you can see some
biofluorescence there
which could be a microorganism who knows
to date we've only really scratched the
surface of Mars we've gone two to three
inches with curiosity but this is
definitely going to happen question is
when I hope Meyer lifetime if I were to
guess I'd say 20 years the obstacles
facing honey bee and it's drill are
considerable the journey of millions of
miles of violent landing completely
remote an autonomous operation there's a
lot that can go wrong but if it doesn't
go wrong this drill could be more than
just a tool it could be the first thing
that ever discovers if there's actually
life out there